[музика]
заграта ми старалися його не
ви знання нацистам і так і щогла наодинці
і жити а ваші за те, що ви не був і
психічних злодій імідж та інвалідів та
жорстоко ли нацистська системи не знала
миша вище тут у так звання
націонал-соціалісти дж не встановиш
смерті зон енштейн bel ami ст-шка pernod
у скинії не менше не було близько 15
тисяч людей нацисти називала з евтаназією
нині тут розтушовані пермський меморіал
зун енштейн у пам'ять про жертв cs краще
не висувають близько 75 років ким у
організовану бун тестовим
програми учасники приїхав та зніме
шини Польщі та Франції
Ізраїлю то США їм раз побачу тих
функцію нуво до нацистського центру
евтаназією в замку зун енштейн я
перебрався спеціальний персонал із сади
stick центр вивідним знати найстрашніших
mist нацистських краще немає його стане
шервуд шері скільки жертв а ми той
змінив у ясних за допомогою газу ви
пробували відразу тисяча дев'ятсот
сороковому 40 по шуму руках взводом був
і ви просто не в канцтоварах так ефект
освенцім для винесення євреїв ми проц і
знаємо це навіть денавіч ці акули ти
знаю зараз залишилося, а вона не можеш
south відомі ти машина смерті в
кулачному госпіталі зон енштейн запустив
з з тут ви мало золоті зуби і розтинав і
мискою що дня спалю вали тіла праху
вали сси , млинцями виставок та про
причиною смерті ізольди багатого бджіл
дріт 100 зло чини ставок і євреїв тут
їжу видів все про новий розділ starring у
евтаназію як і ось перебувала в тіні тут
багата що зберегла seat загадки
ще сни прикуті за і відра mantova
ними фасадом і за дикий усьому тут багата
чого можна в ти
вона вам знайома
тут ви want оживав і купив знаєш інших
просто нас hill день пам'яті жертв
Голокосту тут мешкає по особливому
[музика]